so a little bit about me my name is
Marina and I am a data scientist at the
intelliner have any of you guys heard
about intelliner do you know what we do
okay yeah great
um all right so so we are um an act tech
company we help farmers uh make their
farming and taking care of the fields
more effectively
um so we take basically what we do is we
take imagery from satellite or from
airplane providers and we analyze those
images different ways we have both
analytic algorithms which I work on and
we also have machine learning algorithms
for different types of problems we show
some different alerts for example we
might tell the customer that they have a
weeded area they have some water locked
Parts over there and maybe give them
some advice as well on what they can do
I am also a master's student a second
year Master's student at year one State
University majoring in applied
statistics on data science and I'm also
interested in general operational stuff
devops mlops and data engineering as
well
all right so like I said we mostly work
with field imagery
we do image processing data analysis on
that and the tasks that we solve vary so
we might have some classification tasks
where we try to decide whether a field
is planted or not or is emerged or not
and stuff like that we have segmentation
tasks where we try to uh
find out the parts that are we did or
maybe we want to find the parts that are
soil and actually unmanaged so we don't
need to track them we don't need to
calculate them in our statistics and
stuff like that
so uh each of our models in production
has its own dockerized image that gets
all of these different types of
imageries you can see the first one over
here is just the regular RGB image that
is taken we have the infrared which is
colored here in red we have thermal and
other stuff that I didn't want to show
here we have also topological and other
things which are more difficult to
process
so basically we wanted to inverse
something on a specific field we would
need to have all of this imagery we
would need to pre-process it to kind of
combine and calculate different
statistics indices that are more
important for uh specifically field
processing for example the last image
that you can see here is called an ndvi
which is a vegetation index and it shows
how well the greenery is growing there
so this is something that has
significantly more value
um for for the model than using these
images separately for example so yeah my
main point is that we have one
dockerized image that is running on a
GPU instance because it's going to do
all of the pre-processing it's going to
do the inference it's gonna do the post
processing so whether it needs to
calculate some probabilities aggregate
results and stuff like that and then
give the result back
um so this was working fine but we had
plenty of reasons to change that first
one being the costs that we were paying
for the instances so they um like I said
um our models were running on AWS ec2
instances the types that we were using
were P2 because these are the ones that
have gpus and high Ram because we needed
a lot of memory to pre-process the data
that we had and let's just remember the
price for the lowest one which is 90
cents an hour
okay so another problem that we had with
these type of instances was the
scalability because these models are um
these these types of instances are quite
popular it's often
um not very convenient but you you won't
always have them available so this
capability was definitely a problem for
us
another thing was uh for different uh
types of models that we had they might
have some slight uh differences some
data sets uh for training let's say
would be similar but the work would be
done twice because there was no sharing
in between the code so that's basically
my next point which is duplicated work
and also no versioning so everything was
kind of mixed up if you wanted to update
the data set halfway that would wouldn't
be very
um very correlated
um so it would it it will be difficult
later to find out what you were doing
why you decided to change some stuff so
um the I think that my main point here
is the the high costs and the
scalability these are the top ones that
made us decide to restructure and uh
here are the points that we decided to
implement for the transition
um the star of the show is obviously
gonna be the Triton server because that
is the new thing that we discovered this
year and I'm also going to talk about
the other changes that we added to our
production
so the first one I'm going to talk about
is the ml service
so what we call ml service actually has
three main components the API which we
are going to use to talk to our database
some python classes that we implemented
to make that job a little bit easier and
the database itself the first two are
not really important because the first
one is just we use the fast API which is
a web framework
to to work with databases in Python it's
it's like a restful API in Python the
other classes that we implemented was
just for our is because we were doing
very specific things like uploading a
model registering a data set making some
inferences and saving their results
which I'm gonna talk about in a minute
uh so that all of that was made much
easier
um with with our custom methods and then
the database itself
so where did another database and we
decided to do I mean you you can store
anything you want here for your
convenience this is what we did uh
firstly we registered the data set so
depending on uh what project you're
working on or how you got the data set
you can register it here you can add
some comments you can add tags you can
remember later how you decided to choose
this
and you can also have some versions so
for the example that I brought where
maybe you are training a model and then
some time passed and now you would like
to update your database and retrain
again the versioning makes it much
easier to store and keep track of
the next one are the models and
versioning again similarly so
um when I talk about registering a model
it's gonna involve both
um actually having the model in the
database or writing down that we have
this model of this version which it
automatically will keep track of
and also uploading the model to a
repository or maybe you are using an S3
which we are so we are going to uh we we
created a model repo which is going to
have each type of model and its
versioning there
foreign
like I said to each of these you can add
custom tags comments for models you can
have maybe some configurations and stuff
um and the last table that was also very
important for us was one where we kept
the inference results
um again similarly you can keep some
metadata here
you can keep some computation times you
can keep some statistics I don't know
maybe the mean and standard deviation
interest you for a particular image that
you are processing for example and the
the general inference results this makes
it much easier to keep track of how your
model is performing I have the three
most important points right here so the
first one being easy evaluation so you
can just run all of your inferences
store them in a database and then later
whatever metrics you want to get you
want to calculate some type of different
losses or you want to calculate average
metrics you can it all becomes just a
query and it's dynamic
you can also gather other computational
statistics so in your database you can
keep the inference time you can keep
information about how much of the GPU
you are using how much CPU you are using
how well uh you are utilizing your
resources basically
and then also Track Performance so maybe
you have an imbalanced data set or maybe
you have some very specific examples
that you are interested in you can look
at how the different versions of the
model performed on that specific example
you can visualize that it the all all of
this becomes much easier when you have
just a database it becomes much easier
to work with
all right now let's talk about the
Triton inference server so this is an
open source serving software that is
developed by Nvidia
and it is basically made to
um to execute and deploy AI models
um easier
on mostly on GPU instances of course
so there are several good things about
it first one being how many things it is
supported by so it supports a bunch of
different Frameworks the most popular
ones I guess being pytorch tensorflow
tensor RT which is again developed by
Nvidia and I'm going to talk about later
but it also supports Uh custom backends
if you wanted to write something in
Python for example
as for the platform support I mean it is
mainly uh developed to be used on GPU
instances but you can also scale it to
use on a data center on edge platforms
Cloud for CPU it is also uh it is
possible to run it on a CPU only
instance although it's not recommended
because you are doing you are probably
doing heavy influences
So This Server is going to become
basically a rest service where just like
in any RS service you are going to make
calls in our case you are going to make
post requests to the server giving it
the model name and the data that you
want to
run the inference on this is a little
bit of the backhand so you can see that
the server can manage multiple gpus
it is a really really optimized so
you can run several different models on
the same GPU for example
you can it automatically schedules the
tasks so you can also make asynchronous
requests to it and then get the results
it does its own health checks as you
will later see it's all client also does
its own scaling and load balancing so
it it basically takes care of everything
yeah I think that's all I wanted to say
here so
um the way I said previously our entire
Docker image was stored on a GPU based
instance uh however now we can run the
entire pre and post processing Parts
which I'm going to kind of virtually
separate
um on on just regular CPU machines
because they are not going to use your
GPU resources and then only once the
tile in our case where because we tile
the image to process it
uh once the tile is ready to be passed
through the model you can call
um the Triton server and it it can do
the inference and then you can get the
result
so yeah you can see how the resources
are optimized here
and then yeah like I said the Triton
server has its own python find which
makes everything much easier it does
um it does a load balancing for the
request you are sending it also skills
the service if you are making a request
and there are no servers running in the
servers it will um up a machine
and yeah everybody takes care of the
back end with the mapping to the ipd
addresses as well
all right
um now for the models and how we would
deploy them so each so um the server is
going to have two main types of
configurations
uh the first one being
the one that has all of the information
about all of the models which is not
very interesting because it only has the
model name and the version so I did not
include it here but that's all it is it
has a model name and the version
okay let me take the water break sorry
okay
and the second type of configuration
which we are going to need each model is
going to have one of those and this has
a very specific structure
you can find it on their official
website in the documentation it needs to
be of this specific format it needs to
have a name you can add a platform or a
backend
um the supported ones here are tensor RT
tensorflow and Cafe 2.
and you can have additional information
some models are
harder to work with so you will need to
specify some Dimensions you will need to
specify batch size so there are models
that can only work with one um with
batch size one so you can specify all of
that here
and you will need to
compile the models in order to use them
here
so there is a difference between saving
a model and compiling the model
when you compile it you not only save
the state dictator you don't only pickle
the model itself but
you can also add information about the
losses Matrix Optimizer that you are
using
uh the uh
in Python you have python jit which
takes care of all of that
and get us there is Keras compiled
and again developed by Nvidia there is
tensor RT
which is the fastest one and we compared
uh jit with tensor RT and there was
something like a six-time difference in
speed of inference
and there is also a speed difference
between just Jeet save and party torch
Save which is interesting
another thing worth noting is that
when you save the model indeed it also
preserves uh all of the functionality
that the module has at that moment so
for example
if you were to save a model that was
developed in pytorch 1.5 and then try to
load it in pytorch 1.6 but there was
some functionality changed for example
the division is being done differently
maybe there is some type conversion or
something like that it will not load so
it will tell you that something is wrong
um
another uh so like I said the Triton
server supports tens and RT tensorflow
and Cafe two but an interesting thing is
that you can't convert
every model to transa RT straight up so
what we had to do is we had to convert
our models to jit and then compile them
into tensority
which is also interesting
all right and um
lastly that was I think all about the
restructuring and so now what we were
able to do because of this is we chose
another GPU instance
to run our Triton server you can see
this uh these are the G4 instances and
even on their website they are described
as most cost effective GPU instances for
ML inferences and and trainings as well
so
if you look at the price here it is it
is now about like 50 cents an hour but
uh taking into consideration that
now uh this one server is going to be
able to serve
um in our case I believe it was up to
four different uh inferences and each
GPU can also so each GPU has a copy of
your model if you wanted to utilize that
if you have a bunch of different tasks
to do
um uh so so
we were able to change the instances
from P2 to G4 this is only for the
Triton server
for the pre and post processing you can
use any other regular instance depending
on how much memory you are going to need
for your other actions that you are
doing it can be R5 it can be M4
something like that
and as for the resources so the main
resources that you can use is available
on the um on the Nvidia website they
have the official documentation they
have a quick start guide
so you can get started with that from
zero like I said it's open source so the
images are available to download you can
if you want me to just play around you
could
the official GitHub is also linked here
so if you go to Triton inference server
they have both the HTTP client and the
servers here
there is one tutorial I found while I
was researching which is again pretty
good if you wanted to start from scratch
this is going to help you and yeah I I
would say generally just use their
website because
they have a bunch of different tutorials
they have specifications about
documentations
um also if you are doing
um if you are going to be doing it on
AWS I believe they also have the
um the images there on AWS Marketplace
so that will make your job even easier
um yeah I think that's that's all I
wanted to say I I would also like to
give a special shout out to our
engineering team who implemented all of
this and now I am able to talk about it
here yeah and that's it thank you so
much
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
thank you for for a great presentation
uh did you try another inference Service
uh for example torsor for pytos models
or Tiff serving for tensorflow models
and maybe compare these
return
uh not not really I mean we have we
haven't tried
tensorflow because we we mainly work
with pytorch
um the uh the python serve I'm I'm not
entirely sure if we have tried that
um
thank you
yeah thanks for your talk I'm curious
you've told about the six x speed up you
got from tensor RT could you describe
the modal uh or the architecture of the
model that
gain such a speed up for 10. we we
mostly use cnns I think to so we tested
regular resonates and I think on resnet
50 we got three three times the speed
um for the for the one that had a six
time speed maybe it was some type of a
unit
okay great thanks
so what are the possible like problems
or mistakes that you can faced or have
faced while doing this
oh what do you mean
going to the servers oh well while
moving to the servers I mean
um in initially uh the the kind of
concern that we had was moving the data
from one instance to another because
previously we were doing everything on
just that one instance there was no data
sharing basically
and in this case we were we are passing
basically those tiles of data through an
API request but since all of that is
done in AWS Network everything is really
easy so you don't really have to worry
about that either yeah I would say that
was our main concern initially but we
didn't have to worry about that
can it take to move from to to like
to bring your data on everything to that
server like
um so for for the server specifically I
mean you aren't really bringing any data
to it because
the image is ready all you need to take
care of is compiling the models
correctly which is going to be a change
that you do code wise in in the way that
you work in your production
um everything else is just available to
you like I said it's open source so you
you have everything available to you the
repos
um you only need to add configurations
to them you have the image which you
basically run on an instance so yeah it
like uh upping the server for yourself
shouldn't be that difficult
yeah I think
it's for thought
have you ever worked with the models
replacing replacing model in the
production by these techniques or a B
testing when the model is actually using
there
when the model is actually there and you
have the new version of the train model
yeah for updating or a B testing having
a different model yeah so so if you are
updating a model version the Triton
takes care of that by itself so you only
need to add the configuration everything
else is down there automatically so it
checks both models is what models are
available to it and then it
automatically downloads them if it needs
to it has one specific repo which I
forgot to mention but Triton needs one
specific model repository where all of
the models should be kept the names must
match the folders it needs to have
specifically the versions inside them
the model needs to be in one of those
three formats I mentioned so all of that
is very specific and otherwise you only
need to change the version number in the
configuration and once the Triton gets
up again
scales or something like that it's going
to change it automatically and change
the the model that it's running on the
GPU
[Applause]